we got some very interesting news
yesterday about the American
relationship with Saudi Arabia
if you've been listening to this show
for a while you've been watching the
show for a while you know that I have
been saying for what a decade and a half
the United States really needs to
reevaluate its relationship with Saudi
Arabia now we understand why the
relationship exists there is a sort of
General shared interest in calm in the
Middle East between the United States
and Saudi Arabia and this relates to oil
prices and oil production and for other
reasons and that has been a major factor
in the relationship between the U.S and
Saudi Arabia a cut to the New York Times
yesterday Joe Biden vows consequences
for Saudi Arabia after oil production
cut
the article reads angered by the
Kingdom's decision to team up with
Russia President Biden signaled openness
to retaliatory measures including a halt
to arm sales and allowing price fixing
lawsuits this is a very good article in
the Times by Peter Baker and it reads
that Biden vowed yesterday to impose
consequences on Saudi Arabia signaling a
rupture in the relationship between two
longtime allies and a reversal of
Biden's own effort to cultivate the
energy-rich Kingdom this all relates to
last week's decision by saudi-led OPEC
uh OPEC plus a Biden staff announced he
would quote re-evaluate the entire
relationship with Saudi Arabia and
expressed openness to retaliatory
measures offered by Congressional Dems
such as curbing arms sales or permitting
legal action against the cartel this is
as much about the direct relationship
with Saudi Arabia as it is about the
Russian war in Ukraine and we have to
see whether these are empty empty words
or not are these empty threats are these
just vague promises that will never
become anything or is this something
real again
I did not have particularly high hopes
for Joe Biden when
I decided I would support him over
Donald Trump he was the obviously
correct decision over Donald Trump for
any sane person even remotely Tethered
to reality but my expectations were
quite muted about Joe Biden and despite
a period of about three or four months
five or six months maybe even during
which very little that I could point to
and say this is a good thing has
happened Joe Biden's presidency has
really uh sort of taken a turn for the
better and it would be another great
thing from my perspective if Joe Biden
were to reevaluate this relationship
consider the reality of Saudi Arabia I
mean first of all
funded 911 most hijackers were Saudi
killed and dismembered Saudi journalist
Jamal khashoggi there has been
essentially no accountability war in
Yemen with massive human rights abuses
by the way I mean with some American
support the United States hands are not
exactly clean of blood there either
um important to measure to mention
state-sponsored
Theocratic misogyny and depression
although it has improved slightly over
the last 10 years
economically supporting Russia in their
war in Ukraine this has been an alliance
for oil purposes and for general
interest and stability in the Middle
East purposes and in particular with the
United States I mean listen is it as
fast to move away from fossil fuels as I
would like no not nearly but in
particular with the growing priority of
the United States under Joe Biden much
more so than under Donald Trump of
furthering alternative and renewable
energy usage and getting away from
fossil fuels
there is less of a need in a sense to be
cozy with what is a very backwards
dictatorial state so if we were able to
detach ourselves from the I guess we'll
call it the teat of Saudi oil it's a
good thing long term now the truth is
that the global situation is much more
complicated that I'm making it out to be
in this segment there are many other
considerations there are all sorts of
triangles in which you have the United
States and Saudi Arabia and some other
country which are important
considerations as well from a foreign
policy standpoint but it would be one of
the greatest things Joe Biden could do
to cool that relationship off it's been
something I've been calling for for a
very long time now in the short term the
problem is that this action by Saudi
Arabia will cause Energy prices to go up
and if Joe Biden did indeed take some
substantive substantive step to cool
that relationship and to reevaluate it
will probably cause energy prices to go
up even more and we're getting into
winter where home Energy prices are an
important thing the increase in in
Energy prices will almost certainly be
used against Joe Biden in 2024
Republicans will be able to say listen
Biden chose to do this with Saudi Arabia
and this made everybody's home energy
costs more and gas prices
there's no doubt that Republicans will
try to do that
it's easy to say well it's worth it
anyway well for some people it's an
extraordinarily difficult situation to
have an increase in gas prices or a Home
Energy prices home heating prices Etc
that will be an effect and it will be
they will try to use it against Joe
Biden
at some point the decision has to be
made to back away from this absolutely
horrifying relationship with Saudi
Arabia and I always say there's no
better time than the present if you
disagree with me let me know you can
find me on Twitter at dpacman and we'll
be back after this very short break
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium CBD designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report CBD helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use CBD as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels CBD oil is awesome the CBD infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free Focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about CBD dosage finding the right
starting point and when you join the
feels monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today day and get fifty percent off your
first order with free shipping when you
go to fields.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below